[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con este jueves
4 de febrero se celebra el día mundial
contra el cáncer enfermedad que provoca
alrededor de 10 millones de muertes al
año en todo el mundo por ello nos
acompaña el doctor carlos eduardo pérez
asesor científico de france 24 y médico
infectólogo de la universidad nacional
de colombia doctor gracias por
acompañarnos nuevamente según la ope s
en la región de las américas del cáncer
es la segunda causa de muerte se estima
que 4 millones de personas fueron
diagnosticadas en 2020 y 1.4 millones
murieron por esta enfermedad y hay cada
vez más casos entre las personas jóvenes
le pregunto por qué
si el cáncer realmente es una enfermedad
que es avasallante nosotros tenemos como
inconvenientes en accesos al sistema de
salud en medidas preventivas la
estrategia por ejemplo vacunación de vph
casi exitosa en otras partes del mundo
hasta ahora está creciendo en nuestra
región
las situaciones ambientales que hacen
que el cáncer sea una enfermedad que
sean mastique más rápido y obviamente en
poblaciones más joven que están
accediendo al sistema de salud gran
desafío y sobre todo en estos tiempos de
pandemia es volver al diagnóstico y dar
tratamiento oportuno a este tipo de
paciente y es que doctores lo son el 20
vino acompañado por esta pandemia de
coronavirus que perturbó nuestro modo de
vida pero también generó retrasos y
aplazamientos en los tratamientos contra
el cáncer a veces por el propio temor de
los propios pacientes como se ha visto
afectados y qué consecuencias ha tenido
la pandemia para ellos
sin duda la gran bandeja que viene ahora
es las enfermedades crónicas
desatendidas cosas en el cáncer tan
sencillas como una citología vaginal una
endoscopia digestiva
un examen biológico que hace el
diagnóstico temprano del cáncer se han
perdido porque las personas han perdido
la confianza en sistema de salud y los
mismos confinamientos pues han obligado
este tipo de retraso eso que va a hacer
que los estadios de cáncer sean más
avanzados cuando se haga el diagnóstico
y mucho más complejo es el tratamiento
por eso es retomar la confianza en
sistema de salud y generar estrategias
de detección temprana que lo que sean a
intentarse lo hoy en día
ahora doctora de manera de que estos
pacientes con cáncer puedan sentirse
tranquilos a la hora de recibir sus
tratamientos o asistir a sus citas
médicas mientras atravesamos todos esta
pandemia además pueden los pacientes de
cáncer vacunarse contra kobe 19
es una pregunta clave porque las las
instituciones que tratan sobre cáncer
hacen una estrategia que se llama code
frío de o libre de kobe para que las
personas puedan acceder tranquilo y
seguramente los pacientes con cáncer
pueden ir a las instituciones y se les
ofrece un tratamiento seguro con todas
las medidas necesarias para controlar
que no haya infección por kobe pero
también la buena noticia es que no hay
contraindicación para la vacuna si tiene
cáncer incluso se está recibiendo el
tratamiento como una quimioterapia si
disminuye la efectividad pero se puede
vacunar es decir que hay que retomar las
actividades en cáncer hay que volver a
las instituciones hay que confiar en las
instituciones y se pueden vacunar doctor
repreguntó cuáles son los tipos de
cáncer más comunes en nuestra región y
qué tan lejos estamos de encontrar
tratamientos y curas más efectivos
y los cánceres más frecuentes son los
cánceres de piel de dios por los
gastrointestinales donde el sistema
genitourinario y los pulmonares son
cánceres muchos de fácil diagnóstico por
ejemplo el melanoma que son los cánceres
de piel con la consulta oportuna el
dermatólogo hacer valer acerca de
cambios de curación de piel en los
gastos intestinales con la pérdida de
peso los genitourinarios con una
citología vaginal o con un examen de
próstata son estrategias simples que
debemos hacer siempre que tenemos que ir
al médico priorizar la atención médica
porque el diagnóstico temprano con ya
repito y la clave para el tratamiento
efectivo doctor brevemente la
organización mundial de la salud estima
que el número de personas que serán
diagnosticadas con esta enfermedad
podría aumentar hasta en un 55 por
ciento para el año 2040 que se puede
hacer para prevenir el cáncer
ir al médico vacunarse del ph vacunarse
de hepatitis b que son dos cánceres que
se pueden prevenir con vacunas y hacerse
exámenes sencillos común endoscopia una
citología al final consultada el urólogo
y al dermatólogo son elementos sencillos
y hacen que esta epidemia nueva que es
el cáncer sea diagnosticada
oportunamente y tratada oportunamente el
95 por ciento el diagnóstico seca del
cáncer se trata y se cura si se
diagnostica oportunamente doctor como
siempre gracias por estar aquí con
nosotros en france 24 que tengo ustedes
un buen día
hasta que cinco minutos con hasta una
próxima oportunidad
[Música]